it's been more than three months since
russian tanks rolled into ukraine
leveling parts of the country
and disrupting the post-war world order
in the process it's the most shocking
moment for global security since the end
of the cold war
from the risk to the global economy to
the looming nuclear threat we ask our
experts how the conflict has already
changed the world
and how its effects will be felt for
years to come the rest of our lives are
quite likely to be shaped by the
consequences of this
[Music]
war i will never forget that moment at 3
30 in the morning uh when the telephone
went by my bed and i had uh my deputy ed
carr on the other line and he simply
said it started i think the world has
been
really fundamentally changed certainly
europe has been fundamentally changed
from europe's energy security which has
been transformed and is being
transformed in a matter of months
to
europe's defense which is again going to
be completely transformed the western
order the transatlantic alliance
tested more unified than it has been in
a very long time and obviously depending
on the outcome of this war looking very
very different but i think more broadly
globalization fundamentally changed for
several reasons firstly the imposition
of an extraordinary array of sanctions
the use of economic weaponry of the most
powerful thought
i think we'll have very long lasting
ramifications
countries outside of
the transatlantic looking at this
feeling being very clearly impacted by
it whether it is through soaring energy
prices through an imminent food
catastrophe
seeing the use of western sanctions in
many ways they are they i think they
feel this is a european war that they
are being profoundly affected by however
and i think this is a big however
it is worth remembering that outside the
north atlantic so outside europe and the
united states
much of the rest of the world is not
really on board
two-thirds of the world's people live in
countries that are either neutral in
this conflict or are in fact supporting
russia
and so the west is itself invigorated
but it has not yet
made the case sufficiently to the rest
of the world that the stakes here are
stakes that matter for them and i think
that's really important so the challenge
i think will be for the west to match
its own
renewed sense of purpose and strength
by convincing the rest of the world that
they too have a stake in this and that a
rules-based order is important
across the world before the war in
ukraine russia's army was seen as
powerful capable modernized
what we have seen in ukraine points to
the opposite and that isn't just
important for the war itself and
russia's struggles in ukraine this will
also have long lasting effects on the
way that the world sees russia
russian military power russian political
power diplomatic power all of it has
taken a huge hit russia is coming out of
this war significantly weakened its
economy is in serious trouble its
diplomacy looks fumbling and inept it
hasn't been able to stop countries like
finland and sweden from seeking
membership in nato and that i think is a
long lasting piece of reputational
damage to the russian state what russia
has done in ukraine is to use its
nuclear weapons as a kind of shield
behind which to wage its war inside the
country and it is said to the west
if you intervene directly if you get
your forces involved and they get in our
way
you will risk a conventional war that
may escalate to nuclear weapons
and that has so far worked russia has
used nuclear weapons to keep the west
out of the conflict and i think what
that does is make nuclear weapons more
important to global security than they
have been in many years and countries
like china may be watching this for
lessons and they may be thinking well if
we want to invade taiwan perhaps we can
also use nuclear weapons as a shield to
keep america and its allies
out of that war and keep them from
intervening so i think that's going to
be the lesson that many countries draw
the way in which nuclear weapons can
still be used not for war fighting
purposes
or anything else but it's a kind of
deterrent behind which you can conduct a
military offensive there are a trio of
effects that you can now see on the
world economy and some of them are
unexpected all of them are far-reaching
start with the most short-term effect
which is that the war has amplified the
inflation problem that was already
rippling through the world economy
because russia is a big energy exporter
and because ukraine is a big exporter of
some commodities you've seen a huge
price shop go through
energy and commodity markets and some
people
think it could even
trigger a recession in the u.s as the
federal reserve has to put its foot on
the brakes harder to try and get
inflation under control the second
big effect uh we can see three months in
to the war in ukraine is on supply
chains and that will take a year or two
to become fully apparent and companies
once again have found themselves
unable to fill shop
shelves with
products struggling to find components
and their manufacturing processes in
chaos but the bottom line is this great
redesign of globalization and global
supply chains is now more fully underway
as a result of of the war
the final big change
that's
visible at three months after the
conflict began
relates to sanctions so western
governments have fired a bazooka at
russia's economy they tried to cut off
its financial system its central bank
and quite a lot of the trade russia does
with the outside world
the big implication of that relates to
china you can guarantee that china is
putting together a more cohesive plan
for protecting its financial system and
economy
from western sanctions that might
actually end up being the single biggest
economic implication
of the war in russia and ukraine well
the world has changed absolutely in a
fundamental way
and i don't think we are through this
story at all i think we're in the first
part russia has itself has changed
dramatically uh in this three months it
would have been very hard to imagine
three months ago
that um some of russia's best and
brightest would have fled the country
would have to flee the country uh in
days after the um the uh invasion of
ukraine
that all independent media would be shut
down
in russia i think it made russia's
regime much more brittle
it
speeded up
the moment when we might see the
collapse of this regime and with it
possibly further disintegration
of russia itself we've also discovered
that ukraine the country that many
people thought was
chaotic and corrupt and not quite a
country
few people maybe could even um point its
borders
on map
let alone history has proved itself to
be a genuinely viable and strong country
that has come together his people have
come together in an extraordinary way
and certainly nobody could imagine that
the war would go on
for three months
and that the there is actually a
possibility of ukraine's victory
thank you for watching for all our
coverage on the war in ukraine please
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe